- So the reports are the Joel Greenberg,
friend of Matt Gaetz in
the Gaetz-Gate scandal,
has reached an agreement with authorities
and has entered into some
sort of plea agreement.
Greenberg's lawyer, Fritz Scheller,
said on the courthouse steps:
- I'm sure Matt Gaetz is not feeling
very comfortable today, alright?
- Now it's not clear if
this is a plea agreement
where you just simply agree to cooperate
in exchange for a light
reduction in sentence
to make things easier on the prosecutor
or if this is a cooperation agreement
where you agree to cooperate against
a bigger fish in this case
that could probably only mean Matt Gaetz.
So we'll see if Matt Gaetz
really is feeling uncomfortable
and we'll see if we see him in court.